bon mes chers collègues je vous propose
que nous commençons notre audition parce
que à la fois on a le plaisir de
recevoir monsieur le ministre je
voudrais pas trop le faire attendre et
ensuite on a un ordre du jour assez
copieux donc monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous avons le plaisir de
vous recevoir ce matin monsieur
Jean-Noël barreau ministre délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications que nous auditionnons
d'ailleurs pour la première fois au sein
de notre commission je ne résiste pas au
fait de recevoir avec plaisir un
yvelinois monsieur le ministre vous
l'aurez compris votre audition s'inscrit
en partie dans la continuité de celle de
Madame Christelle Hedman directrice
générale d'orange de Madame Laure de la
Rosière présidente de larc ainsi que de
celle plus récentes et plus mouvementées
de Monsieur Xavier Niel fondateur du
groupe Iliad free notre commission a pu
constater à plusieurs reprises j'allais
dire l'énervement collectif qui existent
aujourd'hui autour de la question des
tarifs du dégroupage c'est à dire du
prix payé par les opérateurs commerciaux
à Orange en tant qu'opérateur
d'infrastructures historique du réseau
cuivre dans la fermeture est prévue à
l'horizon
alors que l'opérateur historique plaid
pour une hausse de ses tarifs ça nous a
pas échappé à vous non plus la
proposition de révision de ces tarifs de
l'arccepte étant actuellement soumise à
la validation de la Commission
européenne les autres opérateurs
refusent toute hausse Bouygues Telecom a
ainsi porté plainte contre Orange pour
défaut d'entretien du réseau cuivre
tandis que Free ça nous a pas échappé
non plus dénonce une désincitation la
fermeture rapide du réseau et le
maintien dit-il d'une rente historique
injustifiée nous sommes conscients que
cette problématique relève la compétence
de l'ARCEP nous inquiétudes portent
aujourd'hui plus largement sur l'état de
la concurrence et de la régulation d'un
réseau
le secteur pardon qui cristallise
aujourd'hui le mécontentement de
certains abonnés des usagers souvent des
élus et des collectivités territoriales
que nous représentons ici Monsieur le
Ministre quel regard portez-vous sur la
situation actuelle les contrôles
exercices par la recette par l'autorité
la concurrence vous semble-t-il
suffisant pour assurer une injuste
niveau de régulation sans favoriser un
opérateur plutôt qu'un autre d'un côté
il y a les moyens juridiques que nous
pouvons confier en tant que législateur
ou régulateur mais qui sont aujourd'hui
menacés par exemple par la contestation
par Orange de la constitutionnalité du
pouvoir de sanction de la recette mais
il y a aussi de l'autre côté la volonté
politique que nous nous incarnons
ensemble n'est-ce pas aussi le rôle du
gouvernement de remettre tout le monde
autour de la table et de trouver une
solution de sortie de crise
sans la proposition de loi
volontairement offensive de notre
collègue Patrick chaise qui sera
examinée ce matin par la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il s'y rendra et
que nous ne connaîtrons donc pas en
détail ni la recette ni les opérateurs
de télécommunication n'aurait accepté de
publier les plannings et les comptes
rendus de leur intervention de leur
raccordement ainsi que nos notifié des
plans de reprise ou de reconstruction de
leur réseau les plus problématiques donc
soyez assuré Monsieur le Ministre que au
Sénat la volonté politique de faire
bouger les lignes et bien là au sein de
la commission des affaires économiques
nous sommes désormais néanmoins
convaincus qu'il ne faut pas confondre
vitesses et précipitations c'est
peut-être consubstantiel au Sénat et
c'est pourquoi nous accordons une
attention particulière à la qualité à la
pérennité à la résilience de nos réseaux
de télécommunications ainsi votre
annonce récente de la recherche d'un
nouveau deal avec les opérateurs de
télécommunication à particulièrement
fait réagir
réussite bien sûr beaucoup d'intérêt
mais également des interrogations dans
la mesure où le plan France très haut
débit n'est toujours pas finalisé les
raccordements complexes jusqu'au dernier
abonné au dernier maître doivent encore
être largement financé tandis que les
observateurs du secteur constatent le
ralentissement des raccordements à la
fibre optique dans les zones très denses
et les zones d'initiatives privées avant
de brandir une réforme de l'imposition
forfaitaire des réseaux des entreprises
de réseau lui faire au bénéfice des
opérateurs et au risque des
collectivités territoriales ne
faudrait-il pas s'assurer que les
opérateurs finalisent les engagements
auxquels ils ont souscrit
d'autre part une réflexion sur
l'implantation des antennes dont le
déploiement c'est forcément accéléré
avec l'amélioration de la couverture
numérique de nos territoires nous
semblent opportunes nous le constatons
tous l'impression est plutôt celle d'un
déploiement précipiter parfois
désordonnées plutôt qu'une véritable
stratégie coordonnée concertée
d'implantation de la part des opérateurs
à cet égard l'expérimentation prévue par
l'article 222 de la loi et lent
permettant de déroger temporairement en
décision d'urbanisme c'est terminé
l'année dernière monsieur le ministre
nous sommes toujours en attente de la
part du gouvernement du bilan de cette
expérience et nous l'attendons depuis on
va dire quelques mois voilà monsieur le
ministre avant de vous céder la parole
permettez-moi encore de vous interroger
rapidement sur l'actualité numérique
législatives des prochains mois un
projet de loi visant à transposer les
règlements européens sur l'ensemble des
services et des marchés numériques a
récemment été annoncé transmis avez-vous
des informations sur le calendrier
s'agira-t-il d'une simple transposition
ou bien prendrez-vous l'opportunité pour
légiférer sur d'autres sujets et enfin
beaucoup d'initiatives parlementaires se
multiplient nous aurons des propositions
de loi sur
la majorité numerica 15 ans sur pour
lutter contre la haine en ligne
l'exploitation commerciale de l'image
des enfants de moins de 16 ans sur les
plateformes en ligne bientôt sur les
influenceurs puisque notre collègue ici
présente à malgaquer à récemment été
nommé rapporteur comment envisagez-vous
l'articulation de ces tous ces textes
ces séquences numériques et quelles sont
la stratégie et l'ambition qui sont
portées par le gouvernement voilà
Monsieur le Ministre quelques premières
questions avant que ne soit donnée la
parole à mes collègues
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci pour votre invitation et votre
accueil un mot donc sur la question des
réseaux de télécommunications suivi d'un
mot si vous me permettez sur la
régulation des entreprises de l'économie
numérique sur les
le sujet des réseaux de
télécommunications vous avez rappelé
madame la Présidente que
nous arrivons au dixième anniversaire du
plan France très haut débit et du et au
cinquième anniversaire du New Deal
mobile et même si évidemment un certain
nombre de problèmes à résoudre il faut
quand même constater que ces deux plans
ont produit leurs effets à la fois en
termes de calendrier rendre en 2022 80%
des locaux raccordables à la fibre tel
était la promesse du plan français au
débit en 2012 et puis effacer des
milliers de zones blanches année après
année tel était la promesse du New Deal
mobile et si cela a fonctionné et sans
la page budgétaire sans renier le
calendrier initial c'est sans doute
parce que une fois n'est pas coutume
l'État a su travailler au côté des élus
locaux des opérateurs télécoms trouver
le bon équilibre et des responsabilités
et des efforts que chacun devait à
consentir que chacun devait consentir et
le résultat est au est au rendez-vous
comme quoi c'est possible quand dès le
départ on
s'accorde sur la responsabilité l'effort
à consentir pour chacun ceci étant dit
ces succès s'accompagnent de
dysfonctionnement important et vous les
avez évoqué en faisant référence à la
proposition de loi de Patrick chaise je
pense notamment aux problèmes de qualité
sur la fibre qui tiennent à trois
raisons principales la première c'est
l'existence de réseau
historiquement mal dimensionné ou
atypique notamment ses réseaux qui qui
avaient été déployés avant même
financement du Plan France très haut
débit il y a 10 ans et qui ne répondait
pas donc au cahier des charges qui a
ensuite été fixé et qui a qui a servi de
standard ça c'est la première des
explications de des problèmes relevés
par nos concitoyens la deuxième c'est
que nous sommes allés très vite dans le
déploiement de la fibre nous avons mis
10 ans là où le réseau cuivre s'est
déployé en plusieurs décennies en
moyenne depuis 2018 c'est 20000 prises
fibres qui sont déployées chaque jour
dans notre pays et donc quand on va vite
la bonne nouvelle c'est que nos
concitoyens peuvent être raccordés plus
rapidement mais ça ça occasionne
effectivement un certain nombre de
difficultés et le troisième élément
c'est la répartition des responsabilités
dans la chaîne qui lie les opérateurs
d'infrastructures et les opérateurs
commerciaux et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
sous l'impulsion de de des
parlementaires au premier rang desquels
Patrick chaise j'ai Orient
l'été dernier mon action en priorité sur
ce sujet de la qualité et dès les
premiers jours de l'automne la filière à
remis ou présenter un certain nombre
d'engagements qui sortent autour de
trois axes le renforcement de la qualité
des interventions le renforcement des
contrôles et la reprise des
infrastructures dégradées et puis la
reprise des réseaux défectueux nous
sommes très vigilants à ce que ces
engagements qui ont été pris il y a à
peu près 6 mois soit évidemment respecté
le premier engagement c'est celui de de
la part des opérateurs de travailler
enfin de d'établir un cahier des charges
définissant une certification et les
compétences minimales requises sur les
raccordements finaux pour essayer de
mettre fin à ces situations ou des
techniciens se présentent devant les
armoires de fibres sans avoir l'air de
vraiment connaître ce que ce que
requiert un raccordement ces
référentiels de compétences sont
désormais prêt et ils seront intégrés et
appliqués dès la fin du mois d'avril et
en tout cas nous allons y veiller car
des trois engagements qui ont été pris
c'est peut-être celui sur lequel les
opérateurs ont pris le plus de retard le
deuxième de ces engagements c'est le
renforcement de des contrôles par la
transmission des opérateurs par les
opérateurs commerciaux de leur planning
d'intervention et par la mise en oeuvre
du compte-rendu des interventions qui
permet un contrôle mutuel entre les
opérateurs donc ça c'est un sujet très
important puisque entre le point de
mutualisation et le le domicile si un
problème survient il peut relever soit
de la responsabilité de l'opérateur
commercial qui a la responsabilité du
dernier kilomètre ou des derniers mètres
soit de la responsabilité de l'opérateur
d'infrastructures qui à la charge des
points de mutualisation notamment et
lorsqu'une défaillance survenait jusqu'à
présent il y avait une tentation de part
et d'autre de se renvoyer la
responsabilité ce qui pouvait
occasionner des délais très longs
désormais chaque fois qu'un technicien
intervient il doit prendre une photo
avant une photo après de et ce qui est
photo qui sont partagées avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes ce qui permet très
rapidement d'établir les responsabilités
et de même que les plannings de
d'intervention de ces techniciens sont
désormais connus de tous
ce que nous constatons
c'est que les comptes rendus
d'intervention sont désormais fournies
plus de 200 000 comptes rendus
au troisième trimestre 2022 les derniers
chiffres dont nous disposons et les taux
de conformité calculés par les
opérateurs d'infrastructures relèvent
révèlent une aide progression de la
conformité de ces comptes rendus
d'intervention
le troisième engagement je l'ai dit
c'était la reprise des infrastructures
dégradées que ce soit au niveau des
points de l'utilisation ou des
réseaux vieillissants ou mal
dimensionnés qui nécessitent une reprise
globale de l'infrastructure plusieurs
opérateurs ont notifié à ma demande un
plan de reprise de 1000 points de
mutualisation à la recette correspondant
à 450 000 locaux c'est le cas par
exemple dans le département de l'Essonne
ou je me suis rendu pour vérifier
qu'effectivement c'est reprises ces
travaux de reprise intégrale des réseaux
étaient bien avancé donc en résumé la
formation des techniciens en principe
des avancées à la fin du mois nous
restons vigilants car c'est sur ce point
que disons peut-être un peu de retard a
été pris le partage des comptes-rendus
d'information et des plannings des
comptes rendus d'intervention et des
plannings d'intervention des techniciens
ça c'est bien en place et puis la
reprise des points de mutualisation
défaillants est elle aussi bien avancée
par ailleurs larsep à qui nous avons
confié le suivi de ces engagements
organise des points réguliers en
présence notamment des associations
d'élus premier interlocuteurs sur le
terrain nous partageons donc le constat
porté par la proposition de loi du
sénateur Patrick chaise dont l'objectif
est de résoudre les difficultés
d'exploitation constatées sur les
réseaux en fibres optique des
branchements sauvages d'abonnés
malfaçons les armoires de rue
dégradation des réseaux cascades de
rands sous-traitance etc et je remercie
Patrick chaise qui nous a permis et bien
d'obtenir un certain nombre de
concessions et d'engagement de la part
des opérateurs en revanche s'agissant de
la proposition de loi je me permets de
vous signaler une vigilance sur une
postentielle remise en cause du mode
stock j'ai bien conscience que ce n'est
pas tout à fait la volonté de du
président chaise et donc crucial que ça
puisse se matérialiser dans la rédaction
du texte qui sera présentée en séance
publique le 2 mai rendre l'opérateur
d'infrastructures responsable vis-à-vis
de l'utilisateur final oblige les
opérateurs à refondre l'ensemble de leur
contrat mettant un coup d'arrêt au
déploiement j'insiste sur le caractère
massif et contraignant de cette nouvelle
donne car à ce jour c'est l'opérateur
commercial qui assure cette
responsabilité c'est le seul à même
d'assurer les fonctions de raccordement
final le changement de responsabilité de
l'opérateur d'infrastructure à
l'opérateur commercial ne changerait en
rien la qualité des raccordements
puisque les sous-traitants seraient
exactement les mêmes il risquerait de
créer cependant des problèmes de
concurrence certains opérateurs
d'infrastructures étant eux-mêmes
opérateur commerciaux ils auraient
intérêt à privilégier leurs clients
abonnés pour effectuer les raccordements
par ailleurs en supprimant directement
la relation entre le consommateur et son
opérateur un certain nombre d'entre eux
risque de ne pas être raccordés soit de
manière pérenne car cela ne sera pas
rentable pour l'opérateur
d'infrastructure ou dans un temps
beaucoup trop long
pour autant l'idée de renforcer les
pouvoirs de l'Autorité de régulation et
notamment d'audit dans l'article 4 de la
proposition de loi est pertinente force
et de constater que bien que les sujets
de qualité de service soit considérés
comme prioritaire par l'ARCEP depuis 4
ans conscience que les effets peinent à
ce matérieliser et par ailleurs
l'article 5 permettant de sécuriser le
droit des consommateurs des usagers et
lui aussi très utile en prévision du
droit au très haut débit pour tous en
résumé la position du gouvernement sur
la proposition de loi de Patrick chaise
et la suivante le mode stock n'est pas
idéal puisque nous avons je l'ai évoqué
deux acteurs les opérateurs de type
d'acteurs les opérateurs
d'infrastructures les opérateurs
commerciaux donc un partage des
responsabilités ce qui peut occasionner
des frictions lorsque il s'agit
d'établir les responsabilités en cas de
défaillance de défaillance
le choix initial du mode stock a essayé
de de trouver le bon équilibre entre les
avantages et les inconvénients et plutôt
que de remettre en question le mode
stock comme le propose les premier s
articles de la proposition de loi nous
soutenons les derniers articles de la
proposition de loi qui eux veulent
renforcer les pouvoirs de la recette
pour faire si l'on peut dire la police
lorsque les uns ou les autres se
défaussent vis-à-vis de leur
responsabilité et c'est dans ces
conditions-là que nous pourrons soutenir
et à mon avis faire le meilleur usage de
cette proposition de loi
peut-être ensuite pour pour répondre à
votre question et à la présidence sur la
la suite nous sommes désormais à un
moment charnière dans le déploiement du
franc du plan France très haut débit et
mon objectif est très simple il s'agit
de rendre le trait au débit et notamment
la fibre accessible abordable et fiable
pour tous nos concitoyens et
effectivement à ce stade ça avait
nécessaire de trouver un accord avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes car par
rapport à la situation qui prévalait il
y a 10 ans lorsque le plan français au
début a été lancé des éléments nouveaux
surviennent qui doivent nous amener à
travailler ensemble à ce nouvel accord
le premier de ces éléments c'est la
fermeture du réseau cuivre le plan
d'Orange qui est une bonne chose car il
ne serait pas responsable de conserver
deux réseaux le réseau fibre et le
réseau cuivre c'est une aberration sur
le plan ce serait une aberration sur le
plan économique et ce serait une
aberration sur le plan écologique ce que
le réseau cuivre est ièrement énergivore
la dépose du cuivre le la fin du réseau
cuivre ainsi que les Français à migrer
vers un abonnement fit pour continuer à
bénéficier des services téléphoniques et
d'internet et donc crucial de prendre en
compte ce paramètre pour accompagner les
Français dans ce changement et notamment
les éventuels travaux auxquels ils
devront faire face mais surtout pour
s'assurer qu'il y a bien de la fibre
déployée partout sur le territoire et en
l'occurrence sur des zones de
bénéficiant actuellement d'aucune
contrainte réglementaire par ailleurs
d'autres solutions entré au débit comme
le satellite et la 4G fixe sont
accessibles pour pour pallier l'absence
de la fibre cette technologie font
l'objet de subvention grâce au guichets
cohésion des territoires autrement dit
il y a 10 ans le plan France très haut
débit avait pour objectif de rendre
raccordable
nos concitoyens 80% à l'horizon 2022 et
puis tendre vers le 100% quelques années
plus tard mais raccordable ne veut pas
dire raccordé or pour déposer le réseau
cuivre il faut passer du raccordable au
raccordé
et il y a donc il y a donc une marche
supplémentaire à franchir par rapport à
ce que les concepteurs du réseau France
de rugby avait imaginé à l'époque autre
point à prendre en compte celui récent
des plans de dépose d'eg et 3G des
opérateurs entre 2025 et 2030 cette
dépose
va faire baisser les recettes des
collectivités en effet chaque opérateur
verset 1789 euros pour chaque équipement
fixé à une antenne mobile en retirant
les équipements de G et 3G pour ne
laisser que celles en 4G 5G les
collectivités vont faire face à un
manque à gagner deuxièmes élément
nouveau auquel on ne pouvait pas
s'attendre au moment où on concevait le
plan français au débit il y a 10 ans et
puis enfin les récents en jeu
climatiques et géopolitiques nous
obligent à garantir un niveau de
fiabilité des réseaux importants pour ne
pas impacter la vie économique et la
sécurité de nos concitoyens là aussi une
donne un peu nouvelle par rapport à ce
que les concepteurs du plan français au
début avaient à l'esprit il y a 10 ans
évidemment ce nouvel accord ne doit en
aucun cas écraser les engagements déjà
pris par les opérateurs que ce soit sur
certaines zones d'agglomération ou dans
les contrats conclus avec les
collectivités il s'agit juste d'apporter
une réponse à une situation comportant
c'est fait nouveau
nous devons être dans l'action et
prendre en compte les difficultés
structurelles de chacun pour convenir
d'un équilibre avec en ligne de mire la
génération de la fibre et
l'accompagnement de nos concitoyens dans
la propriété de cette nouvelle
technologie mon objectif c'est donc de
préparer et d'accompagner la transition
vers la fibre soit nécessite de répondre
à toutes les attentes de nos concitoyens
ceux qui sont en attente du déploiement
de la fibre pour souscrire un abonnement
mais aussi et surtout ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas besoin et qui ne doivent pas
pâtir du changement technologies dans
leur quotidien cela passe par exemple
par des garanties de tarifs abordables
une personne souhaitant uniquement des
services de téléphonie ne doit pas être
contrainte de souscrire à un abonnement
Internet vous l'aurez compris il s'agit
de faire un dernier effort et de
demander un dernier effort aux
opératoires en tout cas de leur faire
gravir cette marche et je sais pouvoir
compter sur eux et sur le responsabilité
pour répondre présent comme ils l'ont
fait dès le départ son corps de lourds
investissements qui sont ainsi
nécessaires et attendus de leur part et
en parallèle évidemment l'état
s'engagera pleinement dans l'aménagement
numérique des territoires car il ne peut
être mangeable qu'il ne relève du seul
ressort et de la seule responsabilité
des opérateurs nous avons ainsi
conscience que pour certains de nos
concitoyens le passage à la fille peut
occasionner des coûts via des travaux
parfois importants au sein de leur de
leur propriété à l'instar des aides de
l'État pour les ménages les moins aisés
qui souhaitent installer des bonnes de
charges pour leur voiture électrique
nous pourrions imaginer un mécanisme de
soutien similaire l'ensemble de ces
actions vise à rendre effectif un droit
au très haut débit pour tous il s'agit
de garantir aux citoyens l'accès à des
offres très haut débit à un prix
abordable voilà ce que je pouvais dire
l'introduction sur les réseaux
télécommunications un mot sur la
régulation des entreprises dans
l'économie numérique pour confirmer
qu'effectivement madame la Présidente
je présenterai disons à l'approche de
l'été un projet de loi en principe même
si le calendrier reste à la main de la
première ministre visant à
sécuriser réguler
l'espace numérique et en premier lieu de
d'adapter le droit français pour que
puisse s'appliquer deux règlements à qui
sous-résidence française très largement
inspirée de travaux auxquels vous-même
et des commissaires ont pu contribuer
ces dernières années que sont le
Règlement sur les marchés numériques le
Règlement sur les services numériques
qui chacun à sa manière révolutionne la
manière dont nous régulons dont nous
entendons faire respecter un certain
nombre de règles dans l'espace numérique
le Règlement sur les marchés numériques
veut mettre fin à des situations de
concurrence
inéquitable de pratique déloyale d'abus
de position dominante
dans l'économie numérique
et ce faisant le règlement opère petit
une sorte de bouleversement dans le
droit de la concurrence puisque
certaines de ces pratiques auxquelles
des géants du numérique comme on les
surnomme ça donnait jusqu'à présent
était contrôlée à posteriori par les
autorités de la concurrence puis
éventuellement sanctionner mais dans des
délais qui ne permettaient pas de
[Musique]
rendre justice si l'on peut dire au
plaignant c'est à dire aux entreprises
qui subit qui subissaient ou qui qui
souffrait de ces pratiques commerciales
de ces pratiques commerciales
inéquitables je prends un exemple
lorsque vous faites l'acquisition d'un
smartphone
le constructeur du smartphone va vous
imposer assez naturellement vous imposer
jusqu'à présent un navigateur un moteur
de recherche un assistant personnel si
vous êtes une entreprise française qui
développe un moteur de recherche
français bon courage pour entrer sur ce
marché dès lors que tous les
utilisateurs de Smartphone on part
défaut accès à un navigateur qui est
pré-installé sur leur téléphone ceci est
une pratique de vente liée qui
auparavant aurait été constaté par une
autorité de la concurrence qui aura
essayé d'établir si oui ou non il y
avait captation d'un marché et
éventuellement aurait sanctionné
quelques mois ou quelques années plus
tard l'entreprise en question cette
pratique au terme du Règlement sur les
marchés numériques sera désormais
interdite dans tous les États membres de
l'Union européenne et un constructeur de
smartphone devra offrir le choix à
l'utilisateur du moteur de recherche du
navigateur ou de l'assistant personnel
qu'il préfère et il en est ainsi de 25
autres pratiques considérées par comme
déloyale qui seront d'ores et qui seront
désormais interdites dans tous les États
membres de l'Union européenne sous peine
de sanctions pouvant aller jusqu'à 10%
du chiffre d'affaires mondial ou 20% en
cas de récidive
voilà pour le règlement sur les marchés
numériques le Règlement sur les services
numériques lui vient faire rentrer les
plateformes de réseaux sociaux et de
place de marché dans l'air de la
responsabilité
aux origines
lorsque Internet a été réglementé au
départ les hébergeurs tels que c'est
plateformes de réseaux sociaux ou place
de marché ont été considérés comme si
l'on peut dire des entrepôts n'ayant pas
de responsabilité vis-à-vis de ce qui
était entreposé en leur saint c'était la
vision que d'ailleurs défendait la
France et l'Europe d'un Internet ouvert
qui puisse faciliter la communication et
l'échange on voit bien avec le
développement de la contrefaçon par
exemple sur certaines places de marché
la prolifération de la désinformation de
la haine en ligne du Cap
cyber-harcèlement sur les réseaux
sociaux que cette logique ne tient plus
et qu'il fallait donc établir un nouveau
régime de responsabilité et c'est ce
c'est ce que c'est ce que fait le
Règlement sur les services numériques
adopter lui aussi l'année dernière sous
présence française qui va imposer un
certain nombre d'obligations nouvelles
et d'interdiction
plateforme de réseaux sociaux et de
place de marché comme notamment celle de
de modérer les contenus illicites et les
contenus qui leur sont signalés
comme le fait de s'abstenir de faire de
la publicité ciblée sur les mineurs
comme le fait de devoir faire auditer
leurs algorithmes par des autorités
extérieures et comme le fait de devoir
partager leur donner avec des
chercheurs qui pourront analyser le
fonctionnement de ces plateformes
en cas de de non-conformité avec les
obligations fixées par ce règlement qui
est lui aussi d'appliquer sur directe
les pénalités pourront aller jusqu'à 6%
du chiffre d'affaires et en cas de
récidive jusqu'à une interdiction
d'opérer sur le territoire de l'Union
européenne c'est de règlements son
application directe il nécessite
néanmoins que le droit français puisse
être adapté pour qu'il puisse
correctement s'appliquer que les
autorités nationales chargées du
contrôle de ses obligations puissent
être du Mans désignées et c'est le cœur
du projet de loi qui sera présenté mais
qui pourra
qui sera l'occasion comme les
propositions de loi que au mois de mai
le le Sénat aura à connaître de débattre
de ces questions de régulation
qu'évidemment le Règlement sur les
services numériques et le Règlement sur
les marchés numériques n’épuisent pas
complètement
et pour nourrir ses discussions j'aurais
cité notamment les les travaux émanant
du du Sénat je pense à ceux sur
l'industrie de la pornographie un
chantier transpartisan d'ampleur qui a
décliné les potentiels de régulation du
secteur au rapport de Madame Florence
blatrix compta conjointement réalisé
avec Catherine Morin de saillie
précisément sur les enjeux relatifs au
DSA EDMA mais également le travail de
Madame la présente Sophie prima sur les
enjeux et propositions d'action visant à
accroître notre souveraineté
technologique notamment en matière du
cloud sujet sur lequel Bruno Le Maire et
moi-même sommes extrêmement mobilisés
mais on peut citer également les travaux
sur la cybersécurité les rapports de
Serge barbarie Rémi Cardon et
Anne-Catherine Loisier qui ont été
produits récemment pour ce qui est de la
concurrence et de la souveraineté
économique européenne plusieurs rapports
élaborés par Patrick chaise Alain
Châtillon Franck Montauger et Amel gaker
matière de lutte contre la haine en
ligne je pense aux travaux législatives
de Yves Boulou et enfin concernant le
contrôle parental les travaux législatif
de Sylviane Noël
il s'est livrable
avez-vous vous vous savez que
les bonnes idées ne tombent pas du ciel
et ayant moi-même été
parlementaire je connais la qualité de
de ces rapports qui qui permettent de
préparer précisément les les évolutions
dans le dialogue entre le gouvernement
et le parlant donc en résumé
notre combat pour un intérêt de plus sûr
et qui tape pour nos concitoyens ne se
limitent sans doute pas à la mise en
oeuvre de du DMA et DSA même si ce sont
des acquis
extrêmement importants ces efforts de
vigilance accrue nourris par les
propositions des des chambres
s'incarnera dans les prochaines semaines
par un texte du Gouvernement et pour
l'enrichir j'organiserai des temps
d'échanges et de travail avec tous les
parlementaires qui le souhaitent afin
qu'ensemble nous portions un texte
ambitieux précis et concret pour
répondre aux enjeux auxquels nous
faisons face voilà madame le Président
pardonnez-moi d'avoir été un peu long
mais ce sont deux sujets d'importance
majeures pour notre pays et nos conc
itoyens très bien merci beaucoup
beaucoup monsieur le ministre je vais
donc laisser la parole à mes collègues
nous allons commencer par Patrick Chaize
et peut-être je vous laisserai réagir à
ces questions après puisque Patrick doit
rejoindre la commission pour sa ppel
commission du développement durable pour
sa pbll à 10h Patrick merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le ministre
pour vos propos liminaires donc
effectivement je m'excuse auparavant de
vous quitter avant la fin de cette
audition pour rejoindre la commission
aménagement du territoire alors vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le Ministre
la France est en pointe sur beaucoup de
sujets qui concernent le numérique que
ce soit le déploiement le choix du FTTH
mais aussi que ce soit sur les mesures
environnementales voir les mesures de
sécurité et on peut s'en féliciter et
considérer que cet exemple français
puisse prospérer chez nos voisins
européens alors j'ai bien entendu votre
soutien à la PPL que je vais donc
discuter tout à l'heure avec la
commission aménagement du territoire
avec quelques exceptions mais je
voudrais tout de suite
effectivement évacuer un sujet qui est
présenté par les opérateurs parce que je
pense que ça les intéresse de le
présenter comme ça qui est de dire que
cette PPL remet en cause le mode stock
je veux dire en aucun cas et à aucun
moment dans aucun article on dit le mode
stock est à bannir alors même que je
remarque dans tous les autres réseaux
ce n'est pas l'opérateur commercial qui
réalise le branchement que ça soit
l'électricité le gaz l'eau ce sont les
opérateurs d'infrastructures qui
réalisent leur raccordement des abonnés
finaux et ça fonctionne donc je veux
dire quelque part dans le numérique ça
devrait pouvoir fonctionner mais soit
encore une fois je ne le remets pas en
cause l'idée qui est dans cette PPL
c'est d'accompagner les engagements qui
ont été pris devant vous monsieur le
ministre et de faire en sorte que ces
engagements soient un petit peu acté
dans un document un peu plus fort que un
accord
entre deux parties sur un coin de table
par la loi donc je suis persuadé mais
vraiment persuadé que dans le débat
qu'on aura début mai nous allons nous
retrouver sur une position commune qui
permettra en fait de répondre à la
question qui est vraiment à la question
de la qualité des raccordements pour nos
collectivités et nos concitoyens
alors j'ai fait donc en introduction je
veux dire une présentation très positive
de ce qui se passe sur le numérique mais
il y a toujours un mais il reste
effectivement un certain nombre de
choses à faire mais la présidente a
évoqué le tarif du groupe page vous avez
évoqué le foncier pour les pylônes de
téléphonie mobile on a parlé de la
qualité des raccordements de l'ifère
tous ces points en fait sont aujourd'hui
des chantiers à part entière et j'aurais
donc une question simple à vous poser
c'est selon vous quel est le chantier
essentiel et prioritaire qu'il faut
engager dès aujourd'hui et enfin une
deuxième question parce que j'ai promis
d'être court deuxième question c'est que
lors de l'audition effectivement de
Xavier Niel il y a quelques semaines ici
dans cette dans cette commission il a
évoqué la possibilité donc même la
demande quasiment d'un New Deal et
j'aimerais avoir votre position sur ce
sujet je vous remercie
c'est le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
je crois que sur le sujet de la
proposition de loi on est aligné avec la
position du du rédacteur c'est à dire
la nécessité de conserver ce mode stock
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas sans défaut
de le corriger avec notamment à
l'article 4 le renforcement des pouvoirs
de
contrôle de l'ARCEP
et de faire dans le même temps respecter
les engagements qui qui ont été pris
puisque je crois que tout le monde peut
s'accorder ici pour pour dire que il
serait trop dommage que les problèmes de
qualité sur la fibre
si l'on puis terniss le tableau d'un
chantier industriel qui est une fierté
française la France grâce à ce plan
France très haut débit se situe à la
tête des pays les plus avancés dans le
déploiement de la fibre en Europe c'est
pas tous les jours qu'on peut se réjouir
d'une d'une telle réussite industrielle
dans notre pays et donc on ne doit pas
laisser ternir ce tableau par des
problèmes de qualité et la proposition
de loi vient apporter un certain nombre
de réponses
sur le chantier le plus important
je pense que le chantier le plus
important c'est c'est celui que
j'évoquais dans mon introduction qui est
de franchir la dernière marche si l'on
peut dire de ce grand chantier de la
fibre et de passer du raccordable au
raccordé et pour cela il faut trouver un
accord et le président de la Vicat à
lui-même appelé à ce nouvel accord avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes état
opérateur et collectivités pour relever
un certain nombre de défis les défis du
génie civil dans le domaine public comme
dans le domaine privé puisque si nous
sommes à 80% de des habitations dans
notre pays qui sont raccordables les 20%
qui restent vous imaginez bien que ce
sont probablement
les habitations qui sont les plus les
plus difficiles les plus coûteuses à à
rendre raccordable
il y a la nécessité pour offrir des
garanties suffisantes à nos concitoyens
pour leur permettre de basculer de leur
abonnement cuivre vers leur abonnement
fibre de tarifs sociaux de débit minimum
et puis d'une aide à l'installation dans
le domaine privé lorsque les travaux
peuvent
représenter des coûts très significatifs
on le voit un effort financier assez
significatif qui va nous voir falloir
porter ensemble et comme cela a été fait
il y a 10 ans au moment où ont commencé
ce grand chantier du plan France très
haut débit et où collectivités états et
opérateurs se sont mis autour de la
table pour se répartir l'effort de
manière équitable et juste il nous faut
maintenant nous mettre autour de la
table pour faire ce même partage de
responsabilité et d'efforts à consentir
pour franchir cette dernière marche et
puis préparer la bascule définitive du
cuivre vers la fibre ensuite sur la
troisième point qui est celui du New
Deal d'abord vous dire une nouvelle fois
que le New Deal continue d'avancer les
dotations comme vous le savez au
département se font au rythme escompté
et nous aurons donc identifié à peu près
5000 sites à l'horizon en 2025 5000
zones blanches effacées définitivement
de la carte de France
même si il faudra attendre jusqu'en 2027
pour que les sites tous les sites soient
entrés en fonctionnement il y a encore
des délais de de 12 à 18 mois pour pour
la mise en service d'un site est-ce que
nous aurons définitivement résolu tous
les problèmes d'accès au réseau mobile
probablement pas et c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour anticiper sur cette ce
chantier auquel sur lequel nous nous
pencherons à ce moment-là nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé à la NCT de
sonder les équipes projets les équipes
projets qui comme vous le savez
attribuent les dotations départementales
au site en attente d'une couverture nous
leur avons demandé de faire remonter les
besoins qui seront nécessaires à l'issue
du New Deal mobile donc en gros
l'objectif c'est bien de de terminer le
la première génération du New Deal et
puis de commencer à anticiper sur les
besoins qui resteront non satisfaits à
l'issue de ce grand plan
si Monsieur le Ministre merci Patrick
Sylviane Noël ensuite Bernard bus
autre question merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre il y a
tout juste une année le Parlement adopté
la proposition de loi de Bernard de
Bruno Studer visant à couragés le
contrôle parental
sur les équipements et services vendus
sur Internet et permettant
d'accéder à Internet pardon proposition
de loi dont j'ai été rapporteur et je
souhaite donc profiter de cette position
pour vous interroger sur plusieurs
points que pouvez-vous nous dire sur
l'état des consultations publiques
menées sur le projet de décret la
Commission européenne et les autres
États membres ont-ils transmis des
observations Gouvernement sur ce projet
de décret pouvez-vous déjà nous dire à
quelle date celui-ci sera publié et
enfin pouvez-vous nous indiquer à partir
de quand l'obligation d'installer un
dispositif de contrôle parental par
défaut sera effectif pour les Fabr
icants de terminaux et les fournisseurs
de système d'exploitation je vous
remercie
merci Sylviane Bernard but et ensuite
Franck Montaugé merci président de
madame monsieur le ministre je souhaite
vous interroger sur l'articulation de la
fermeture commerciale du réseau cuivre
par Orange avec la couverture fibre
optique vous l'avez déjà évoqué
l'objectif de 80 % de fibres optiques en
2022 et quasiment atteint au 31 décembre
avec 34,4 millions de locaux
raccordables à fibre sur le territoire
national sont entre 709 et 80% de
couverture mais on observe des
disparités territoriales fortes de 91%
des locaux couverts en zone très dense à
68% en zone moins dense d'initiative
publique même si ces dernières on la
dynamique la plus positive puisqu'elle
représente 73% des déploiements de 2022
ma question est simple considérez-vous
que l'objectif de 100% fibre sera
atteint lorsque le réseau cuivre sera
fermé on nous parle de 99% en 2025 et
100% en 2026 pour les cas les plus
difficiles est-ce que vous préparez un
plan pour assurer la continuité pleine
de services dans les territoires où la
fibre arrivera le plus tard et donc
pourrait rencontrer des difficultés
opérationnelles inhérentes à la fibre en
service de ces infrastructures par
rapport à la nature je pense notamment à
quelques fermes dans le haut Diwa mais
pas que ça vous va très éloigné des unes
des autres par ailleurs Ardèche Drôme
numérique and Drôme Ardèche qui est
l'opérateur public nous annonce
aujourd'hui 3% qui ne seront pas
raccordés voire jamais raccordés car
trop cher donc comment est-ce qu'on va
pouvoir régler cette problématique ma
deuxième question porte sur un autre
sujet c'est l'intelligence artificielle
qui est générative et ses conséquences
en matière d'emploi elle inquiète autant
qu'elle fascine notamment à propos de
ses conséquences en matière d'emploi si
de nombreux acteurs estiment que
l'intelligence artificielle risque de
supprimer nombreux emplois d'autres
estiment que les conséquences pourraient
être positives à l'image de l'expert de
la tech américaine ce George Nahon qui
estime que l'intelligence artificielle
générative créera plus de métier qu'elle
n'en élimine est-ce que vous partagez
cette analyse
merci Bernard Franck montoget ensuite
Serge Mériot merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation donc en tant que ministre
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunication comment je sais que
c'est un sujet qui
qui vous intéresse parce que vous y avez
travaillé n'écoute pas comment comment
évaluez-vous les politiques d'accès au
numérique et de transformation
numérique de l'économie
est-ce qu'il existe produit par votre
ministère ou d'autres des bilans
périodiques de suivi de l'efficacité du
déploiement de ces politiques numériques
donc au service de l'économie française
un sujet illustratif
particulier de cette question générale
l'attribution des fréquences en cours je
crois de la bande de la bande de virus 6
GHz quels sont vos objectifs en matière
d'accès à la 5g+ pour les professionnels
donc
quels sont vos objectifs politiques en
matière d'accès à l'accès ing+ par cette
bande et en ce qui concerne la
transformation numérique des entreprises
quelle que soit leur taille c'est
important et où qu'elle soit sur les
territoires c'est important aussi et
enfin quelle évaluation faites-vous et
le cas échéant comment de notre
souveraineté numérique nationale si le
thème n'est pas pas assez de monde et il
vaudrait mieux qu'il ne soit pas en tout
cas me semble-t-il merci
très bien merci
dans mon département alors en Dordogne
pour ne pas le citer mais un habitant
sur 5 n'utilise pas
internet ou n'a pas les compétences
numériques pour y accéder qui fait au
total 75000 périgourdin comme ça vous
connaîtrez la population du département
sont donc en situation d'électronisme ce
phénomène n'est pas propre à ce
département alors que les services
publics se digitalisent que nombre de
démarches administratives sont désormais
uniquement numérique la question de ces
oubliés d'Internet est essentiels
d'autant plus essentiel qu'elle est
concomitante avec le niveau de vie et de
diplômes et de la catégorie sociaux
professionnelle par exemple les ouvriers
les agriculteurs sont sur représentés
mais la fracture numérique se crée
également quand on s'attarde sur les
revenus
internet représente un effet un coup en
celui du matériel ou de l'abonnement
entre autres il est donc nécessaire de
mettre les moyens pour aller vers ces
populations et les accompagner c'est
probablement le rôle de l'État peut-être
pas lui seul mais de mener cette action
de lutte contre cette inégalité et ma
question c'est où en est votre stratégie
de lutte contre l'électrolisme et de
réservation de résorption des zones
blanches et puis également qu'en est-il
de la couverture alors je parle pas de
la 5G mais au moins de la 4G dans les
zones rurales
Serge Alain Châtillon suite Évelyne
Renault garabédian
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je voulais simplement vous
intervenir sur un sujet qui me touche
beaucoup sur la Haute-Garonne et sur le
Tarn et l'Aude secteur où nous avions
une société qui s'appelait Scopelec
[Musique]
l'agence aujourd'hui ne travaille plus
et la déposé le bilan puis dès l'instant
où Orange a souhaité se séparer de se
sous-traitant c'est pas loin de 4000
salariés qui se sont donc arrêtés et
depuis rien n'avance rien n'avance dans
la mesure où on ne voit personne au
travail les poteaux tombent en bois sur
le cuivre le cuivre est très souvent
enlevé et pour l'instant la fibre on la
voit oui on la voit enroulée au-dessus
de certains poteaux c'est tout donc
depuis huit mois je me mobilise mais je
ne vois rien arriver donc comme je vous
ai senti très positif sur le
développement je voulais vous demander
d'intervenir au plus vite pour que on
puisse trouver des solutions et ce que
le
nouveau sous-traitant d'orange est à la
hauteur des espérances d'orange
[Musique]
un exemple je vis à Dubaï je suis suivi
par un million de followers dont une
grande partie sont des mineurs et je
fais la promotion de centre de pratique
esthétique en France le texte prévoit
l'interdiction de la promotion d'actes
de chirurgie esthétique comment cette
interdiction
s'appliquera-t-elle à mon cas
particulier influenceuse français
française installée à Dubaï merci de
votre réponse
merci et Évelyne Jean-Claude Tissot
ensuite Anne-Catherine Loisier si elle
revient
voilà
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'aurais juste c'est des
compléments d'informations parce que
dans votre propre éliminaire vous en
avez parlé à propos de la raie du réseau
cuivre ce chantier pose la question de
l'entretien du cuivre pendant la durée
du plan d'ici 2030 certains territoires
ruraux dépendent encore de 25% du réseau
cuivre et il conviendra rappeler que
l'arrêt de la commercialisation du
réseau cuivre est prévue dès le 1er
janvier 2026 et compte tenu de la
généralisation et vous l'avez dit de la
fibre qui doit être assurée au 31
décembre 2025 mais l'extinction du
cuivre a déjà commencé depuis 2020
l'opérateur historique n'est plus en
charge du service universel de
l'entretien il n'est plus soumis à
l'obligation vous l'avez dit et c'est
votre souhait de déployer le réseau
cuivre
et c'est quand même il y a certains
paradoxes quand même c'est que certains
logements en cours de construction ne
sont évidemment enfin donc plus
raccorder au cuivre mais non pas accès à
la fibre donc quelle coordination avec
les élus quelle communication auprès des
Français pour conduire ce dossier
essentiel pour nos territoires c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
toujours dans le réseau cuivre vous nous
avez annoncé monsieur le ministre que
les négociations avec les opérateurs
télécoms sur la création d'un droit à
très haut très haut débit devrait
aboutir au premier semestre 2023 ce
droit doit permettre aux citoyens de
prétendre à une connexion Internet d'au
moins 30 mégabits de seconde et à des
tarifs réduits pour des plus précaires
d'entre eux ma question est simple
comment avance ces négociations à propos
de l'hifères j'ai pas bien compris ce
que vous nous avez dit vous avez fait le
constat et on fait tous le même constat
que le fait de démantèlement ou
démontage les collectivités vont avoir
un manque à gagner comment imaginez-vous
combler son manque à gagner est-ce que
vous avez une un scénario voilà et puis
donc voilà et puis
sur sur mon territoire j'ai aussi
Scopelec qui a qui a pris de plein fouet
le non renouvellement de contrat est
orange donc je rejoins mon collègue qui
a posé la question merci Monsieur très
bien Anne-Catherine loisirs et ensuite
Christian Redon sarrasie merci Madame la
prison merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre engagement et notamment pour votre
engagement sur une PPL cyberscore qui a
été portée par par le Sénat qui est un
outil pour mes collègues de à la
disposition des particuliers outils de
mesure de la sécurité de la protection
des données personnelles sur les grandes
plateformes que nous utilisons de plus
en plus donc je voulais savoir Monsieur
le Ministre dans quelques mots ou en est
ce dossier on avait eu l'occasion de le
suivre
donc à quelle échéance pourrait-il être
mis en oeuvre
second sujet sur les raccordements
complexes je crois que vous vous l'avez
évoqué ma question serait surtout de
savoir comment est utilisé cette
première enveloppe de 30 millions
d'euros dont on sait que elle ne sera
pas à la hauteur des besoins qui sont
estimés à plus d'un milliard donc qu'en
est-il de la mise en oeuvre et qu'en
est-il d'une éventuelle reconduction ou
d'une augmentation de cette enveloppe
pour répondre donc on à cette nécessité
des de raccordement de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens sur le décomissionnement du
cuivre effectivement c'est un sujet dont
on parle de plus en plus moi je
m'interroge sur la la méthode choisie
par Orange est-ce une méthode choisie ou
subie en tout cas je constate je l'ai
évoqué lors de l'entretien que Xavier
Niel que sur mon territoire de Côte-d'Or
un certain nombre de communes
paradoxalement fuiles dispositif en
disant non non je ne veux pas être dans
le dispositif d'expérimentation ce qui
est quand même un comble et qui me
semble mal augurer de de ce grand enjeu
de des commissionnement du cuivre voilà
donc est-ce que on pourrait avoir un peu
plus d'éclaircissement sur la stratégie
choisie par Orange sur la sur la
spéculation foncière je crois que vous
en avez parlé aussi je sais que la pelle
de notre collègue propose des solutions
concernant les sites nouveaux mais qu'en
est-il monsieur le ministre décide
existants avec vous le savez ces
entreprises qui viennent faire des
offres alléchantes aux communes en leur
proposant de multiplier les gains de
leur loyer et aujourd'hui j'avoue qu'au
moins quand je suis sur mon territoire
je rencontre régulièrement des communes
qui sont saisies et qui ne savent pas
quoi faire donc qu'en est-il par rapport
aux sites existants et à cet enjeu
majeur de ne pas avoir des pylônes vous
parliez du New Deal et l'enjeu d'un
peut-être d'un nouveau New Deal mais il
faudrait pas qu'on commence à enlever
des pylônes de l'ancien new delle enfin
de New Deal actuel voilà donc il y a un
vrai sujet d'information aux communes et
puis enfin dernière question sur le DMA
DSA je voulais savoir si le texte
s'intéresse aussi au crédit cloud
gratuit notamment largement distribué
dans les universités vraiment un sujet
préoccupation puisque il capte tous nos
jeunes voilà nos jeunes générations avec
vous le savez des frais de sortie
exorbitants donc est-ce que le texte va
jusqu'à aborder ces points stratégiques
merci merci Anne Catherine Christian
Redon sarrazzi merci monsieur le
ministre je reviendrai sur un sujet qui
vient dévoris Catherine ma collègue
Catherine moisi qui a été abordé aussi
au niveau de la csnp où je siège donc
qui concerne les twerko ces fameuses
sociétés qui viennent essayer de
s'approprier des des
du foncier et quand on sait l'enjeu du
foncier sur les années à venir en terme
de déploiement de nouvelles unités c'est
particulièrement important donc je crois
que le lien qui peut être fait avec les
communes et particulièrement et la
formation qui peut être donnée
doit être particulièrement éclairante
là-dessus sur les enjeux à venir mais
moi je voulais vous interroger sur la
cohabitation je dirais de trois régimes
en quelque sorte le voyez c'est l'ami
qui est bon maintenant assez
ancien mais sur lequel il reste dans
nombre de d'agglos des raccordements en
nombre à effectuer avec donc des
opérateurs Orange en particulier qui
polémique un petit peu parfois sur le
sujet a été évoqué ici avec la recette a
été évoqué avec Orange sur le nombre de
raccordement à
terminer à boucler et c'est
particulièrement important dans
l'optique du déconomie mission du cuivre
mais aussi la cohabitation entre de
lamelles avec les rips on a un salon de
territoires ou cohabitent ces deux modes
de développement et il y a notamment le
problème des infrastructures qui
aujourd'hui sont mutualisés entre du
cuivre souvent donc par Orange et de la
fibre qu'en sera-t-il le jour où il y
aura dépose du cuivre où il restera des
infrastructures qui ne seront qui seront
utilisés par des rips par exemple et qui
seront la propriété d'opérateurs privés
je vois venir des grosses difficultés
dans l'entretien
notamment d'Emma par exemple des poteaux
avez-vous prévu quelque chose autour
j'irai de ces futurs négociations qui
devront avoir lieu ou en tout cas de des
conflits parfois même
qui peuvent apparaître dans cette
cohabitation en quelque sorte
par deux questions je crois que je les
avais posé mais vous avez
emporté dans votre élan oublié d'y
répondre sur l'expérimentation qui était
prévue à l'article 222 de la loi élan
voilà où en est le rapport et est-ce que
est-ce qu'on aura ce fameux rapport et
deuxième question qui était au centre
des polémiques sur l'arrêt du cuir du
cuivre évidemment orange dit que le
réseau coûte de plus en plus cher à
entretenir et on voit bien chez nous que
ça doit être vrai parce que il est pas
en très très bon état donc on comprend
qu'il y a des charges à faireantes aux
réseaux cuivre qui sont importantes et
qui et qui sont une justification pour
les hausses de prix demandé par le
dégroupage pour par Orange et en même
temps quand on écoute Xavier Niel on
peut pas dire qu'il a tout à fait tort
en disant que les abonnements sur le
réseau cuivre étant inférieur aux
abonnements de la FIP ce n'est pas une
incitation à la transformation donc quel
est votre point de vue sur ce voilà
Monsieur le Ministre une question
sympathique
pas toujours mais parfois
je vais je vais utiliser un premier
joker pour la question de la présidente
sur l'article 222 car je n'ai pas la
réponse mais je m'engage à la trouver
d'ici la fin de la matinée et d'un
informer hein
non non mais de savoir où il en est à
quel moment il va pouvoir être présenté
s'agissant du du tarif du dégroupage il
m'appartient pas de le commenter il faut
qu'effectivement le bon équilibre se
fasse l'objectif étant et restant que la
migration puisse se faire dans les
meilleures conditions je vous ai parlé
de ce qui est du ressort du gouvernement
dans le dialogue avec les collectivités
les opérateurs qui est le le nouvel
accord mais ce nouvel accord se fait
dans un cadre
de régulation qui est fixée par par
l'autorité administrative indépendante
qui en a la charge
sur les questions
de Sylviane Noël sur le contrôle
parental le décret est actuellement au
Conseil d'État il devrait sortir et
devrait en sortir mi-mai et il faudra
donc un an
avant que les les
constructeurs de terminaux je le
rappelle un tout tous les terminaux des
smartphones aux consoles de jeux vidéo
en passant par les tablettes
seront obligatoires munis d'un système
de contrôle parental répondant au cahier
des charges fixés par ce décret et
l'obligation s'appliquera un an après sa
publication effective
votre question va nous permettre aussi
de d'être en veille et de et de nous
assurer que dès qu'il sortira du Conseil
d'État il soit il soit pris dans les
meilleurs délais
sur les questions de Bernard buy
l'objectif est bien d'atteindre la
complétude à l'horizon 2025 pour que à
partir de 2026
l'extinction du réseau cuivre puisse se
poursuivre
ce ce niveau de complétude qui va se
situer quelque part entre 99% et 100%
va dépendre dans certaines zones qui ne
sont pas encadrées ni par les
obligations fixées aux opérateurs dans
la zone amie ni par les contrats dans
les réseaux d'initiatives publiques
c'est à dire dans la zone très dense va
dépendre de l'accord que nous allons
construire à l'horizon de la fin de ce
de ce premier semestre
mais l'objectif est bien que ce soit
dans la zone très dense qui comme vous
l'avez rappelé est un peu plus avancé
même si la dynamique qui est moindre que
dans les zones où la dynamique est forte
mais où le taux de de Loco raccordable
et bien en deçà il s'agit d'atteindre la
complétude la plus aboutie possible pour
préparer le déploiement du cuivre où
est-ce que le retrait du kiwi où est-ce
que la fibre
ne pourra pas être déployée ce sont des
dérogations qui sont fixées par l'ARCEP
et qui sont très restrictives ce sont
les lignes ou le cuivre n'était pas
présent initiatives initialement les
refus de tiers et au cas par cas
certaines lignes excessivement chères et
sur ce dernier point qu'est-ce que
la charité est relative est une notion
relative sur ce point le régulateur
effectue un travail d'analyse
ensuite sur la question que que vous
posez sur l'intelligence artificielle
qui va qui va être l'objet d'un débat
cet après-midi au Sénat
les premières études dont nous disposons
sont assez parcellaires elles semblent
évoquer que l'intelligence artificielle
générative
va s'installer comme un complément à
l'intelligence humaine dans une majorité
des métiers un peu de la un peu de la
même manière que les moteurs de
recherche sont installés dans le
quotidien de beaucoup de quotidien du
monde du travail de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens en tout cas ceux qui sont
dans des dans des secteurs du service ou
de l'industrie etc et ces études font
état de d'une proportion
un peu plus faible mais mais néanmoins
assez assez
remarquable d'emploi qui pourraient être
directement menacé mais ces études sont
quand même très préliminaires et en
vérité
toute technologie
a des conséquences sur le marché du
travail il nous appartient de les
anticiper grâce au travail qui a été
mené depuis cinq ans à la suite du
rapport de Cédric Villani nous avons
comme vous le savez mis les bouchées
doubles sur la recherche et la formation
en intelligence artificielle avec
notamment la création de ce qu'on
appelle les 3ias les instituts
interdisciplinaires pour l'intelligence
artificielle à Nice à Toulouse à
Grenoble et à Paris qui ont permis de
démultiplier le nombre de diplômés le
nombre de de chair en intelligence
artificielle qui est une manière de se
préparer à cette arrivée prochaine sur
le marché du travail de ces technologies
sur les questions de Franck Montauger je
rappelle que je partage avec lui le
souci de l'évaluation de nos politiques
publiques s'agissant de la fibre je
signalais le rapport de France
stratégique qui est sorti il y a
quelques semaines et qui analyse en
détail les impacts de d'abord
l'atteinte par ce plan de ces objectifs
et puis son impact économique et qui est
un rapport très dense et très riche puis
s'agissant d'une New Deal mobile le
rapport de la Cour des comptes de
septembre 2021 qui qui en fait une une
évaluation
assez détaillée dans les deux cas plutôt
insatisfait site qui est donné même si
comme je le rappelais tout à l'heure le
travail n'est pas terminé puis sur la
question de la souveraineté je vous le
dis et
je vais rien je vais rien dire de très
de très innovant ici nous avons un
retard à combler et les rapports
notamment celui de la présidente mais
mais d'autres rapports sénatoriaux ont
montré que nos entreprises
françaises notamment se trouve
s'agissant des services du cloud qui
était évoqué à l'instant dans une
situation de dépendance excessive à un
certain nombre d'acteurs très concentrés
situés à l'extérieur de l'Union
européenne sur les questions de Serge
mériou rappelait ces chiffres
qu'effectivement
nous avons
obtenu la semaine dernière grâce à un
rapport détaillé du créé que j'avais
demandé au CREDOC et au créaad pour
caractériser l'éloignement numérique ce
sont un Français sur trois qui sont
éloignés du numérique soit parce qu'ils
ne sont pas internautes soit parce
qu'ils ne se sentent pas compétents
cette proportion ne baisse pas elle a
plutôt tendance à augmenter et cette ce
chiffre n'est pas le résultat d'un
phénomène générationnel c'est un
phénomène social puisque le visage des
éloignés du numérique c'est celui des
ouvriers c'est celui des personnes moins
diplômées c'est celui des personnes qui
sont dans les zones rurales plutôt que
dans l'agglomération parisienne et ce le
visage aussi de ceux qui du fait de ce
sentiment de de relégation que peut
provoquer l’oignement du numérique se
détourne des urnes puisque ce sont
souvent des gens qui s'abstiennent aux
élections c'est donc une priorité
absolue que de d'apporter une réponse à
cela
un premier niveau de réponse a été
apporté en 2021 avec les conseillers
numériques qui ont été déployés sur
l'ensemble du territoire l'attente des
acteurs des élus c'est que puisse au
niveau local se structurer cette
politique d'accompagnement des éloignés
du numérique qui aujourd'hui est
accomplie au quotidien par une diversité
d'acteurs qui vont du secrétaire de
mairie aux responsable de médiathèque en
passant par les travailleurs sociaux et
ses conseillers numériques il convient
désormais et c'est le travail qu'on a
engagé avec les 60 parties prenantes
associations d'élus associations de
médiation numérique qui ont travaillé
sous l'égide du Conseil national la
refondation pour nous livrer une feuille
de route que nous allons restituer dans
dans quelques jours d'ici la fin du mois
et qui va définir comment dans chaque
territoire on va pouvoir identifier un
chef de fil pour cette politique de
lutte contre l'éloignement numérique
quelles sont les moyens associés à cette
politique quelles sont les quelle est la
filière de formation pour les les
professionnels de la lutte contre
l'exclusion numérique mais aussi toutes
celles et ceux qui d'une manière ou
d'une autre y contribue bref de
d'installer au niveau territorial une
coordination de l'action de tous les
acteurs sur ces sujets
sur la question d'Alain Châtillon où je
m'engage à intervenir auprès
d'Orange et de son nouveau sous-traitant
ou de son nouveau sous-traitant éventuel
pour pour s'assurer que le rythme de
déploiement reprenne et je vous propose
qu'on le fasse ensemble c'est à dire
qu'on se mette en lien avec vous sur la
question d'Evelyne Renault Garabedian
sur les influenceurs
je crois qu'il faut saluer l'initiative
prise au départ par des parlementaires à
l'assommational et Bruno Le Maire qui
ont souhaité
qui ont souhaité donner un cadre à cette
activité qui
occupe 150
000 personnes en France avec des
activités très vertueuses on la
découverte scientifique le contenu
pédagogique etc à des activités qui qui
virent parfois à l'arnaque et qu'il
fallait donc pouvoir
encadrer et éventuellement
sanctionner
ceci dit le texte à vocation à être à
être enrichie encore et je pense que le
Sénat se penchera sur les questions que
vous soulevez celle de la localisation
géographique des
influenceurs en question pour en faire
en sorte que nos concitoyens soient bien
protégés et que l'activité de ces
influenceurs qui a vocation à grandir
dans les années qui viennent puissent se
faire dans un dans un climat de
confiance j'ajoute par ailleurs que le
DSA offre aussi une une
couverture une protection de premier
niveau puisque le niveau de
responsabilité
auquel les plateformes vont être
astreintes vont les conduire à renforcer
leur lutte contre les pratiques en tout
cas contre les pratiques qui les
pratiques illicites qui se développent
en leur sein
sur les questions de Jean-Claude Tissot
sur l'extinction du cuivre
et ça me permettra aussi de répondre à
la question d'Anne-Catherine Loisier
simplement rappeler que avec la
présidente de la commission nous avons
en commun d'avoir vu dans notre
département les premières
expérimentations de retrait définitif de
cuivre se produire d'abord avec la
commune de lévis-saint-non ensuite avec
donc qui était la première commune à des
commissionner le cuivre intégralement et
puis ensuite avec la commune de Voisins
le bretonneux qui la semaine dernière a
vu le cuivre s'éteindre de même que la
commune de Provins en Seine-et-Marne et
quatre communes des Ardennes donc si
communes ont été concernées et il nous
est revenu que cette extinction s'était
fait sans grande difficulté même si elle
a permis d'identifier là où se situe les
blocages c'est à dire là où
la veille de l'extinction la veille où
on appuie sur le bouton des locaux n'ont
pas encore fait leur transition mais
sont bien souvent des locaux qui sont
vides ou avec des problèmes de
copropriété
ce genre de sujets là on va s'avancer
vers des des expérimentations avec
beaucoup plus de communes je crois que
c'est c'est une trentaine de milliers
puis ensuite plusieurs centaines de
milliers de d'habitations qui vont être
concernés par les prochaines
expérimentations et s'agissant de lui
faire
oui il y a effectivement une baisse à
attendre de la dépose de la 2G de la 3G
et donc parmi les les éléments dont nous
discutons et dont nous allons discuter
ensemble puisque si l'effortif est
réformé en définitive c'est le Parlement
souverain qui qui en décidera au moment
de l'examen du projet de loi de de
finances c'est pour c'est plus de
lisibilité à la fois pour les
collectivités mais aussi pour les
opérateurs face à une ressource qui va
être très volatile dans les années qui
viennent je reviens sur les
questions d'Anne-Catherine Loisier sur
le cyberscore notamment
un projet qui est très exigeant puisque
il faut définir un cahier des charges
qui va permettre d'afficher à la manière
du nutri-score dans les raisons des
supermarchés un cyberscore pour les
sites les plus utilisés
il faut trop donc trouver le la bonne
formule le projet de décret et le projet
d'arrêter sont actuellement soumis à
consultation publique jusqu'au 15 avril
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine sur le site de la Direction
Générale des Entreprises
ce qui va nous permettre de recueillir
les observations et propositions des
acteurs concernés par l'application du
dispositif
je trouve pour ma part c'est une
initiative sénatoriale que elle est très
bien venue puisqu'elle va permettre de
mettre en valeur les sites qui ont fait
les efforts pour se conformer à des à
des standards de sécurité qui
garantissent que les données
personnelles données bancaires de des
internautes sont protégés et inciter
ceux qui n'ont pas encore fait ses
efforts là à le faire même si nous
veillons évidemment à ce que ce type de
système vertueux ne
disqualifie pas des acteurs français
émergents pour lesquels ce type de mise
aux normes peut être particulièrement
particulièrement exigeant
sur la spéculation foncière que vous
évoquiez également
simplement rappeler que la loi reine
portée par Patrick chaise à élaborer un
dispositif d'information des maires en
cas d'acquisition ou de locaux d'un
terrain en fin d'édification de tout
infrastructure supportant des antennes
d'émission de réception de signaux radio
une attestation de mandat d'un opérateur
téléphonie mobile doit ainsi être
obligatoirement présenté aux maires par
un acteur souhaitant édifier ou rédifié
une infrastructure d'accueil sur un
terrain ces dispositions là qui auraient
sans doute pu éviter certaines
situations qu'on a constaté avec des des
interruptions de services ces
dispositions suscité des atorexiques des
interrogations de la part des élus sur
leur portée ainsi que sur leur modalités
de mise en oeuvre j'ai signé la semaine
dernière une circulaire à destination
des préfets pour accompagner l'envoi
d'une foire aux questions qui apporte
toutes les réponses aux questions qui
nous sont remontées et je vous propose
de vous communiquer cette cette
circulaire pour que vous soyez bien
informé également
alors notre lecture est celle qu'on fait
figurer dans la circulaire c'est qu'elle
s'applique que la règle s'applique à
tous les sites
je crois que je réponds ainsi également
aux questions de
Christian Redon sarrazzi ça je la garde
pour la fin
mais j'ai peut-être arrivé au bout des
questions si c'est pas le cas je vous
prie de mon excuser
[Musique]
bon sur les crédits cloud
qui ce qui figure au rang de ces
de ces pratiques
anti-concurrentielles
même si elle est perçue par certains
certaines entreprises innovantes comme
un moyen de financer ou de co-financer
leur développement cela fait partie des
sujets auxquels nous réfléchissons et
qui qui pourrait éventuellement figurer
dans le dans le texte mais comme je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure
l'objectif de de cette audition étant de
couvrir un certain nombre de sujets je
vous propose que
ultérieurement et dans les semaines qui
viennent entre maintenant et la reprise
après la coupure on puisse avec les
sénateurs et sénatrices intéressés
évoquer point par point les les éléments
du projet de texte de manière à ce que
vous puissiez les vous préparer à les
corriger et les enrichir le moment venu
très bien Christian oui
sur cette question là je vous propose de
vous revenir
c'est la première fois que j'ai cette
question là mais je vous fais une
réponse détaillée une fois que j'aurais
bien j'aurais bien analysé
très bien pas d'autres questions
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup de
cette audition et de ses réponses j'ai
l'impression qu'on a du pain sur la
planche ensemble dans les semaines et
dans les mois qui viennent mais comme
vous le savez le Sénat est sur ces
questions de numérique dans la diversité
des sujets très allant et il y a
beaucoup de compétences ici dans cette
commission mais aussi dans d'autres
commissions donc merci beaucoup et à
très bientôt et à cet après-midi en fait
pour le débat sur voilà sur
l'intelligence artificielle merci
beaucoup et merci à vos équipes
je vous propose une petite pause